you feel you can stand against anybody
at your best yes everybody you said I
don't do abs I don't do cardio these
guys are doing two three hours of cardio
a day that's a lot of wear and tear no
joints and bones brother see that's the
thing
I'm from head to toe complete traded I
want to talk about your best friend here
Shawn Ray he are ready to rebut it
what'd he say it already
but I want to hear from you this air is
totally different from 90s Ronnie's
still number one for you all time yes
what did he look like when you're on
stage with a muster here some of my
friends that I've gone to Arnold they
got sick every year that's before I
could want a virus what are some unique
things you were doing you never done
before now let everybody know all it is
when I'm retired give is one that is all
gonna give us one hand there's this
something new thing coming out it's
called athletic on we don't have any
information no one is telling us nothing
we don't even know how much money is in
the damn jokes we can money but you just
placed second on Arnold Classic going up
against everybody that's younger than
you and you look sick you have at least
convinced me enough to say hey I'll
think about it it's only feel couldn't
even do that
yeah say they feel that changes
everything
[Music]
you know a lot of people don't believe
you gonna be done now don't start crying
when you boy gone did you ever think you
would make it take sweet victory I know
this life meant for me why would you bet
on Goliath when we got that a V value
Kaman given values contagious this world
of entrepreneurs we can't no value the
haters honey run homie look what I
become
[Music]
my guest today is the winningest
bodybuilder ever he's won 29 different
contests five-time Arnold Classic no
one's won at more than five times he's
in and on top of that he won mr. Olympia
mr. Olympia masters any Europe all in
the same year 2008 it's the one and only
Dexter Jetson thank mister thanks for
coming out thank you thank goodness good
right now looking at you what's special
about looking at you is you look
competition mode because you just came
from Laurel quest I just beat this past
weekend show so it's the first time
we've had a guest that is three days
fresh off of a competition off of a
contest how you feeling I feel good man
been I've been drinking my water make
sure I stay hydrated you and I've been
eating a little junk food here and there
but I can't go too crazy because I got
to get right back on a diet amaro to get
ready for the long on classic Australian
in two weeks in two weeks
yes so when you're typically preparing
for competition like that that's a no
that's a long ways you guys it fly right
that's a long ways do you typically go
week before and train there or do you
train and then they go you go yes I
usually go I'm actually leaving Sunday
get there Tuesday because you lose a day
so the show is following Saturday of
course so I get there about you know
what for five days before four or five
days before the competition just and
during those four or five days are you
trying to readjust sleep because this is
not like you're going from LA to Ohio or
you know you're going to Vegas you
there's a big difference how you
adjusting your sleep your training your
diet um same thing like you said I'm
trying to just what my sleep diet is
gonna be cool because I have me a prep
company there that'll prepare my meals
for me and then I'll be training there
as well you know probably I get that
tooth out training Tuesday Wednesday and
Thursday and probably take Friday off
and be ready rumbling on Saturday how
you how you're feeling that's gonna go
for you I'm waiting man I ever show why
every show I do it's it's my mindset is
the wind I'm not going in to compete and
play games I'm trying to win everything
I do what happened to one like what
haven't you
one I haven't won Brazil I've actually
won
Arnold Australia I've worn it already
Brazil was it's the only one that I
hadn't won I think I've won everything
else everything except Raziel well not
under the small shows you know the major
show I've won all the major shows Brazil
is the only one that knows did you ever
compete Night of Champions or no did you
I did what what year was that because
that's when Wayne was still put them
together right yeah Wayne was Wayne was
the the president did I think the last
time I competed in that show was 2003
maybe it's one out of three 2002 or
something like that
so how was all know classic I know
obviously you know you're going in
there's a lot of different names and you
know onac wins but how you feeling you
did yourself with the results not to
take nothing away from waiting wins a
great competitor but I was on my game
this week man after the Olympia
I was with this amazing gut specialist
and we've been working on this for
months and it finally got my gut down I
have no more gut you know so that was
one of the main things that was
hindering me from winning or placing
even higher than I have been so now
that's gone I felt that coming into this
Arnold that that was gonna be a
guaranteed win for me because that's
that's the only thing anybody can say
anything about my physique you know I
bought my legs back up my legs was big
and everything so conditioning was crazy
because this this for this competition
actually diet laundry per se I didn't do
all the stuff that you know you always
have I've always had where I said to
myself if if it's not broke why try to
fix it you know so that was things that
I was doing like peanut butter every
night I did that my whole career and I
say you know what I'm gonna actually
follow the diet this time because
there's some reason I'm not getting back
into the conditioning that I used to get
into you know what my abs deep and my
lower abs good and all that stuff I
wasn't
in that so you know I said you know what
let me try something different this time
I'm gonna cut all of that crap out I cut
everything that I used to do that I
always believed in keeping in my diet
you know because I'm the blade and I can
get away with it I cut it all out and I
should be father died and man I was so
peeled and shredded I mean this was days
you know weeks out and we had to
actually slow it down a lot and but as
you saw at 50 years old I was I was
right on point look like I was ten years
ago my body man my waist is tight
everything was so good and I thought I I
thought I pulled I'm weighing out this
past weekend you thought you you oh yeah
of course I thought I want and this is
not just the confidence talking you're
talking technique no Teddy can you want
yeah again I mean you look at the
pictures look at the video I mean listen
it's unbelievable when you look at the
pictures it makes a no sund first of all
it doesn't make sense period let alone
you're 50 years old right that's what
doesn't you know anything I respect what
the judge's opinion I have no I'm you
know there's no bitching and griping
coming on for me and you know their
decision is their decision and I'm cool
with that but me on how I feel I feel
that a bodybuilder has to make
adjustments and try and be better than
he was the previous outing which is what
I did and and once you do that you know
I felt that I was I was I should have
been I should have worn a competition in
what area do you go one by one by one
like are you saying legs boom I got here
I got him here he got me here he got me
or you know you know you don't compare
by the powerful body part you just
compare overall overall package overall
package overall symmetries better than
his my conditioning was better than his
I just you know like I said I just felt
about you don't want got it as far as
right now being 50 competing versus 40
competing 30 competing 25 competing
what's the biggest difference you're
feeling with your body I really don't
feel anything with my body to be honest
with you I don't have any aches or pains
anywhere that newbie machine I use for
my legs
has taken so much pressure off my knees
that I don't feel anything in my knees
so I'm able to go heavier than I
normally you know they're not normally
been going and and it still keeps the
pressure of my knees so that's why I've
been able to bring my legs back you know
what I'm saying so that was the main
thing and everything else my joints feel
good overall I feel amazing I can do
this another 10-15 years if I feel like
you can go another 10 years yeah of
course I can so if you can go another 10
years and why are you talking about
retiring because you know in your heart
when it's time to let it go
it's time it's 22 years it's just it's
time to let it go on top but you
specifically said I will retire when I
stop competing in the top six I did say
that and I have been saying that but but
you want to listen to your mind and your
heart too if my heart says it's time to
let it go it's time to go and go on to
bigger and better things
and that's what it's time to do
interesting you know a lot of people
don't believe you're gonna be done a lot
of people think because and the reason
for this not you know how some people
you watch a play and you say you know I
think he should have retired two years
before well you know what after what I
presented this past weekend a lot of
people are saying that I even thought of
myself for a second I was like hell no
no yo ass is retired so I am really done
you guys gonna be surprised I don't
start crying when you boy gone but I'm
definitely gonna retire this is my final
year and I've always said I'm gonna give
myself you know like you just said i
I've always said as long as I'm in the
top five that's just me talking as long
as I'm in the top five
I'm you know I'm gonna continue
competing yeah or or as long as the body
holds up or whatever it may be
I've always said that but I've never and
I've always said I've give myself a year
to but I've never said I'm retiring this
is it this year I've never said that
this is the first time I've said it I
want to record San it and it's gonna
happen how did that decision come about
how'd you nice to me in like me and my
my fiance we sit on and
and my family talked about it and we
just feel it's the right time any
specific reason for or just well I
thought there were so many other
business opportunities what I have to
pursue right and I can't do it why I'm
still competing it's just too much going
on
you know I'm away from my family a lot
of people don't know that I'm away from
my family probably eight months out of
the year I go to LA State LA just to
Train you know a train with Charles
glass out there I've I had an apartment
out there for ten years now so it's
rough on the family too you know if it
wasn't FaceTime we probably does
FaceTime saves lives saves relationships
so definitely FaceTime is what helped me
and her be able to communicate and we
both got to understand them because
she's the main one to say well look Dex
you need to go out there you know cuz at
first when I started going out there I
started training with jaws class okay
and I was go out there for two weeks
hug all my stuff back to the Florida
stay there for another two weeks then go
back out to LA train with Charles for
two weeks and spending all this money on
you know vehicles to rent and and and
hotels and she says you know what you
need to just find a place out there
just stay out there and train keep all
your stuff out there that when you got
to worry about lugging it back you know
you have everything out there that you
need and then when the show is over just
come on back home and and you have your
family time and I could come out there
and chill out there you know sometimes
there a few times there a year and which
is what we do and so we got a very good
understanding and it's amazing to have a
woman behind you once a person like that
that's gonna support you so guys if you
out there man you got a good woman like
that you need to hold on to that woman
because she is definitely the backbone
of you know what I got going on my
relationship and all that stuff man
she's amazing Cale is and you know so a
lot of people don't know that's the
reason you know you know me going
understand eight months out of out of
the years that can be tough on any
family brother
and but like I said now it's time to sit
down and having a discussion you know I
got so many business opportunities that
I have to attend to now while I'm hot
you know I wanna I don't want to start
losing them to two fools that you know
ain't got no business loser - you know
what I'm saying and then my name goes
down the drain and people I'm not gonna
say gonna drain but but while I'm hot I
need to take those you know take that
and use that you know and get ready for
after bodybuilding yeah you know what
I'm saying it's the part the part I
would say are there guys that you're
seeing coming up that you think it's
gonna be tougher for you to place in the
top five over the next 24 months because
sometimes you know one of the biggest
criticism right now mr. Olympia or
bodybuilding would be you know there's
not really I mean there you got listen
you got Oh Olivia I'm not taking
anything away from more and some of
these guys are coming up but it's not
like the MBA we're giannis is right
behind and you know John warrant and you
got Luke and all these guys coming up
you know if you compete the next two
years you don't think you would do top
five no yeah of course I will I've
always said I say peasant what fear was
coming when I was being field I said you
know what I ain't worried about Theo but
when he comes into his own and nobody's
gonna be him you know I'm saying but
it's about muscle maturity you know
these guys are young they gonna have a
great future but right now they can't
beat me
next - you know one or two years I stick
and hold them off just like I did with
Phil but once they'll beat me there's a
wrap
now look what a lot of people to
understand all the people that have come
and gone and let me explain this what I
mean by that is when I come into the
total body building you had guys like I
mean all the 90s guys right so I come in
all these guys that beat me and then I
start beating those guys you know
flexing you know Chris and and all other
guys stop being everybody okay once I
start beating you you're not coming back
and beat me
okay not coming back and beating me
you're not coming back but the new guys
could be but like I've okay right right
so so now once I start beating you I'm
going up just you gonna start going down
yeah right so I've always said I can
outlast you and come back and start
beating you again once you start beating
me and which is what I've done so a lot
of guys that are coming to the game
Victor and so many other guys that have
come along and branch and wolf all these
guys that come along and start beating
me I start by beating them again so I
ain't worried about them no more mmm-hmm
you know what I'm saying
so I can do the same thing if I can
compete another five six years if I want
to and start beating the branded curries
and start beating all these guys if I
wanted to you know say you think you
could oh yeah of course I could because
I feel it like it still cuz you know I
can still keep the same body for another
five six years I it's not it's not it's
not about being how big you are and none
of that stuff as you know when it comes
to the spirit or the body good it's
about the overall package I'm not a big
dude you know but I'm very very hard to
be when I'm at my best right so when I'm
at my best I can stand up against
anybody I go toe-to-toe with anybody
said Ronnie and probably doing to
somebody you know during was an
incredible bodybuilder but you know me
at my best
I can stand toe-to-toe with anybody you
feel that oh yeah I feel it shows I've
beaten everybody you feel you can stand
against anybody at your best
yes at much I mean go to 2,000 if you go
back to 2000 six seven eight nine six
seven eight nine I stand with anybody
those years I mean cuz you figure I'm -
I was I'm five six and a half and I
weighed 230 235 you know you got
Shawna's five six he way to honey
there's a huge difference you put a
side-to-side
am i conditioning see that's the thing
I'm from toe to toe head to toe complete
you know shredded from head to toe back
then you had guys that were in shape
beautiful shapes and all that stuff
well I'm here to toe they didn't have
some of them had loose hamstrings loose
loops or what have you
hmm you got I was well rounded that's
why one so many shovel that's what a lot
of people to understand but that's not
that big anything about always being big
yeah I remember I read a article about
chewing 99 or maybe 2000 and your
physique you know your physique was I
was in a military or someone you said I
don't do abs I don't do cardio this is
pure genetics yeah yeah yeah I don't I
don't do cardio I don't do abscess
purely genetics how much of your
advantage is just purely your genetics
because the last as long as you have I
mean would you say some of it is
genetics and shamans some of it is
maturity most of it is genetic because
being able like I said coming up through
the years see this is another reason why
I've lasted so much longer than
everybody has ever because the first 10
years I didn't have to do none of that
stuff you're saying I can get away with
cheating every day and still coming to
show shredded no cardio these guys are
doing 2 or 3 hours of cardio a day
that's a lot of wear and tear no joints
and bones brother I didn't have to do
none of that stuff so that saves me
right there that's 10 years off that I
that these guys are doing now I'm doing
some cardio and I'm doing ABS now
because I have to you gotta know how to
make the proper adjustments why 28
minutes by the way I heard you say
multiple times you do 28 minutes of
cardio 25 why 25 22 25 oh so it's not a
a specific mathematical formula are you
okay it's just 20 to 25 minutes that's
all it is okay and you said the the
trainer that you hire to work with your
gut which are amps
what did you do differently there you
never I mean you're 50 years you've been
in this world for a while what are some
unique things you were doing you'd never
done before well I can't I don't want to
get into all of that right now when it
comes to that but because I don't want
all the young dudes or these old
dude beat me right now if I tell him
what you've just won give us one hand
one we'll put it this way is some
SuperDuper probiotics and digestive
enzymes that's medical grade God you
can't I mean there's stuff anything that
you have on shelves supplements you're
talking my most nutritional then that
the method of training no not the method
is to get my gut down yes that's all
nutrition that's all it's a lot of
people I'm gonna tell you this a lot of
people think a lot of people think just
because you're eating healthy that you
got a good gut so they get away from you
want the sugar and guess what they do
and go to sweeten loads and they go to
the everything that's got sucralose and
all that stuff and uh that's the worst
thing you can do that's what that's
that's the absolute worst thing you do
specially over the years of those
bodybuilding so when you have a lot of
guys that's got a big good nine times
out of ten it's because of that and a
lot of people don't realize that I had
hiccups for days and days and weeks and
weeks and I had to take medicine and
hiccups to stop the hiccups and we
couldn't understand I went to to the
Mayo Clinic the Mayo Clinic in
Jacksonville Florida there's three of
those clinics or hospitals around the
world hmm
I'm live around the United States and
they are the number one hospitals in the
United States so they did extensive
testing on me and those you know in the
hospital so I'm up turning I'm saying
probably two weeks of extensive testing
with my blood work and all that stuff
sticking [ __ ] down my throat trying to
figure out what's going on with my gut
well come to find out I had a gut
bacteria so we had to get rid of the gut
bacteria that was one of the reasons why
it was puffy down to the bottom we
couldn't figure that out now I got with
this other lady after after that disgust
specialist and first thing she told me
to do stop all of that stuff that you're
doing with the sucralose
old I sweeten knowing all that diet
stuff knock it off
for now on just take I
I'm gonna tell you I can't tell you what
she told me you're retiring
I'm gonna let everybody know all of this
when I'm retired but you can't tell me
my stomach went flat is help versus what
it was
well that's instantl was electric no a
week system and no it's not instant at
all
because we started at six weeks out from
the lake Ian Cotter
okay and after Olympian I was like and
it came down a little bit I was like in
for temple came down a little bit long
not better than it was a year before so
I was like you know what I'm doing with
the Appeals ignored [ __ ] for me so my
girls like you stay on it and the gut
specials like you need to do this and
keep it staying on it so I stayed on in
the whole time from the Olympia to the
Arnold so that's months three four
months I stayed on it and the desert
resort you see what happened my flummox
tummy was fine a flat again and the
number one thing is a lot of people I
mean those all those sweet and lows and
and and and all that stuff that you eat
with sucralose guess what happened when
I started when I cut that [ __ ] out no
more he cuts gone after you all that
medicine I was taken to stop the hiccups
yeah when I cut that simple stuff and
was gonna interesting now let me ask you
Dex you've been around the game for a
while okay you're 50 you're now for it
that's a big difference between 50 40 30
right right and in the political world
there's some games you play and you know
if some things you say something you
don't how much of the bodybuilding world
is there of giving bad advice to
competitors to have an edge because
everything's about an edge in your world
right it is giving bad advice
some of it is giving good advice some of
it is confusing I mean obviously if
you've seen pumping iron you know Arnold
will try to confuse you know Lou or
Frank whoever he was it wasn't how much
did that happens till today I really
don't know because you know what when I
when I start working with someone I
stick with that one person I don't
listen to what goes on or what other
people are saying you should do this
that's that's one thing a lot of these
competitors do they listen there's too
many people at one time you know so
that's why I've always been a mystic
quit sticking one trainer sticking with
nutrition is pretty much my whole career
I well Joe McNeil was my first choice
Farrell's my second
named nutritionist someone had two
nutritionist yeah in 22 years you know
what I'm saying
and um and with Charles you know he's
been my only trainer in the gym that I
work with what I wanted
psycho Fitness you know for a year and a
half or something like that but I went
back to Charles been with him now for
the last year and a half but that's the
thing you know I've always had people in
my camp that I trusted 1 2 % and I
didn't listen to none of the other stuff
for so I don't really don't know how
much in it everybody else is influenced
by anything got it Charles you said
you've only been training with them for
a year and a half or you you know no I
started training with Charles it's 2010
I trained with it for like seven years
then I went to cycle for a year
been a year and a half you were gone
yeah what y'all what is the big I mean
Charles is obviously you got five people
who talk about he's been written about
every word what makes Charles so special
training with them it's the different
language that he uses and granted a lot
of people like why you need a trainer
you know well why Michael Jordan got a
you know shooting coach mm-hmm
he's the greatest basketball they got a
shooting coach
well the same thing with him you know
same thing you know if there's little
things that and little twists and stuff
that he does when it comes to your
working out and hitting different angles
that a lot of people don't know how to
do he does and not only do does he have
that to motivate me but the main thing
is he's Charles glass when I walk in
that gym I don't want to let this man
down
that motivates me in itself I'm gonna
give it all I got when I train with him
because of who because of who he is it's
his style challenging you pushing you or
no it's just more direction no I can do
it all myself I know how to do all
exercises now but like I said he just
being with Charles and in that gym you
know that goes gym is just it's just
something about that damn gym it's the
most famous gym in the world and some of
the best equipment out there in the
world you know what I'm saying some and
in the atmosphere is just everything you
know you can't go into a gym that's the
atmosphere away there's nobody training
do nothing you're gonna be in the same
mood you know I'm saying so you go to
general everybody's training and busting
my ass
mm-hmm that's what you don't want to do
what's the biggest thing I remember
Dorian Yates said one time you want to
you know Gold's Gym and from this crook
they don't recognize him yeah and say
say you know I'm here I'd like to
transfer where you have to pay 25 bucks
or whatever the number says I'm mr.
Lampe and he says I don't know who you
are so look at that that's me right
there right in it she lets him in yeah
what's the biggest changes you noticed
with your life and the way you were
treated the moment you became a stolen
beer what are the perks the additional
perks the additional perks the
additional perks they are well you know
good relationship right now so you know
we obviously there's different perks if
you're single but what are some of the
crazy perks you get when you're mr.
Olympia well I mean I get a lot of free
stuff I get a lot of people want me to
promote stuff for them and and earn
money off of it my Instagram is through
the roof when it comes to my engagement
so I get a lot of money from my
Instagram so those are those are some of
the perks um what else when I used to be
just a bodybuilder or or if I just say
well say if I'm seconds if I want to you
know I'm somewhere in public and someone
asks me well what do you do you play
football you know I get acts that every
day your football player and I said no
when I want to talk to the people I just
say are my body builders they're like oh
okay
but when I say I'm mr. Napier oh wow
really that that changes everything
just that name alone even people who
don't follow this even people don't
follow the sport they know that name mr.
only leader now you know how in football
you wore a ring and you got all these
other things mr. Olympia doesn't have
anything like that for you to put on no
we don't have anything to put on we got
that Sandow when you walk in the house
seemed I don't know meant yeah yeah
there you got it they gotta give
something you can wear when you go
places you know a raining cuz you know
even a poker they do the bracelets you
know when you win a World Series poker
you want to break
but it would be it would be nice for you
to carry your ring with you and what is
this Olympia right maybe if mr. Olympia
then if you're watching is that's
another idea for you to consider having
drinks I mean the United I mean the
night of the champions or the New York
Pro at the New York Pro gives out a ring
so yeah you know with diamonds it's like
$10,000 you know so so yeah Dan you know
yeah there's something to think about
I would I would definitely consider that
because it's more of a conversation
starter when somebody sees it right what
does that ring for it's for this so so
it what happens with the mr. Olympia
brand when you compete on you win once
is it the moment you win one you can
compete in any other mr. Olympia ever
right if you ever want you can computer
rest of your life what other benefits is
there when you become a store Olympia
winner Hey any other perks free Coke
Zero for the rest of your life they're
like you know create yong-hwa
like I say if if the person that's in
the fitness know you are you probably
get gonna get it get it for free or you
get a good deal so those are those are
the biggest person that was out of
biggest let's go back to auto classic so
I'll know classic when you guys were
competing and the whole controversy
happen with coronavirus how was that
handle when you were going I know about
quarter of a million people I couldn't
go to the expo there was some people
that were partners how was that frenzy
when you're in it what were you guys
experiencing we didn't I mean we were
pretty much in our own element as usual
because you know normally I'm in my room
the whole time anyway when I'm competing
I don't go to the expo anyway you know
no back in the day I used to when I
worked for MuscleTech and stuff we had
to go there for hour and a half or
something like that but as I got older
and don't have a sponsor nutrition
company anymore yeah I don't go to an
expose in him in the morning anyway so
that didn't affect me at all I think for
the people I mean because it's a sad
situation I can understand exactly where
both parties are you know coming from
you know especially Arnold because
this show has been going on so long and
plus you know he's I mean it's the
biggest thing in Ohio it's the biggest
event in Ohio and for them to shut it
down
it was pretty you know without even I
think from what I've heard I'm not going
to position but this is just what I
heard they shut it down without even
consulting him first you know the news
conference and he they call Arnold why
they had the news conference while I was
giving the conference so that was pretty
much a slap in the face but if things
were doing done the right way I can
understand where the government was
coming from as well you know our thing
is you still got Cavalier games that's
got 30,000 people 20,000 people at the
game and that's still going on well in
our event we still had our fans that
night but I can see where they're coming
from because 20,000 versus 250,000
that's that's a big difference
and then those Expos it's all about
touch it man you touching it you bumping
it touching everybody you're kind of
control when you got your own seats you
know so that's why I figured they let us
have our normal night show with
everybody because it's controlled they
already bought these seats and they know
where everybody's at and it's not like
other people are still coming in you
know I'm saying like Expo expose the
ending out people coming from everywhere
all over the works it just that's one
thing I'll people understand these
people coming from all over the world
when you got an NBA game those people
probably just right from clear eyed
unless it's a playoff championship
season game it's local people absolutely
in the honor classic is people coming
from all over the world you know so they
can be carrying anything that makes
sense that's not they haven't been I
know people that has gone some of my
friends that I've gone to the Arnold
they got sick every year that's before
the corona virus that's sick every year
they come go back home they sick or
something you know I'm saying so I can
understand what both parties it was just
a sad situation that it had to go down
you know now that this whole virus thing
is going down man it's sad for everybody
involved you know what I'm saying let me
ask you was there any talks on why the
governor didn't reach out to Arnold or
no those kinds of talks did nobody out
with you guys no I don't know anything
that's not at your level political right
okay and well but in athletes the
athletes were screened you know when we
got off the plane we had to go into
really and we were screened now I don't
know I don't know what exactly this
screen you can do for you but all we did
was do a you know temperature you know
to put the temperature gauge in our
mouth till I took our temperature and we
answer some questions are you from a
different country how do you because it
at this country in this country and
that's it so I don't know what that was
supposed to do maybe if your temperature
was higher than then what they're
looking for they probably would have put
it to the side and there's some more
tests or or whatever but as long as you
you know you your your temperature was
low you was fine so no blood or urine no
blood or you weren't taking that all
forth and no one was asked you can't
compete there was no incident that said
this person cannot comply hey I didn't
know all the guys that that were they're
all competing and and are most of you
guys I mean it's a bodybuilding is a
fraternity right it's it's a group of
people that pretty much do the same
sports so you are competing we're in a
way you also kind of want to get sport
to be getting bigger and bigger because
it benefits everybody right were you
guys all on the same page kind of a with
the decision made for the quarter
million people coming through on the
expo so I think the right decision was
made or were there certain people that
were saying you know I yeah it was it
was next it was mixed
it was mix some wanted it some didn't
want it you know what yeah I think the
whole thing came down to they was
getting a lot of heat from petition you
know people that was put you know people
didn't want this honor this export to go
down whose people that general public
there was partitioning this thing oh I
just know getting all these copyright
that's the main I think for what I
understand that's what really did it for
they made the government step up and say
we you know we need to shut it down
because you would get so many people
complaining about you know complaining
about it yeah I wonder if govern the
wine the
has a relationship with Arnold and if
there's any kind of a connection with
him Trump because you know him and Trump
the whole show and their level of
competitiveness for each other I don't
know obviously the wine is a Republican
or Arnold's a Republican at Trump's a
Republican but Arnold's a different kind
of Republican than the wine I don't know
the decision-making behind of it or
behind it I do know how is this being
talked about for mr. Olympia is there
any talks that if this continues the
same could happen with mr. Lampe oh I'm
pretty sure it can
yeah that's that's pretty in from what I
understand they just said it they just
shut a big event down here in Austin
right it's like for in a town of
people's you know they did South by
Southwest that's the bigger one yeah not
just South by Southwest they're also
doing the one in Miami also which is how
many people show up to alter by the way
what's the number it's gotta be no no
it's got to be a big number it's not
even it's it's a South by Southwest is
massive
this is some interesting stuff here I
mean obviously see but what's so sad
about it Patrick is I was actually
speaking with one of a business owner
there a small business owner as a
restaurant and they got to go out of
business now because they need this
weekend they needed that weekend yeah so
it's so just all the small businesses
man that's that's in trouble they rely
on that competition coming to town cuz
so many people come they flood their
restaurants or whatever and that's how
they make it a lot of their money
through the whole year yeah so a lot of
these companies gonna have to shut down
now because of this year
this whole coronavirus thing and it's
sad it's absolutely sad you know and I
hope one they get to the bottom of it
fairly quickly and make some real
decisions about this to get me a listen
we're one of the most innovative
countries in the world if we want to
create something and solve something we
can do it but this is a time that they
need to you heard about what happened
with Italy Italy northern Italy about 18
million down people shut him down yes
and even in Iran you know folks no one's
taking folks that are traveling whether
it's from China or Iran there's a lot of
it going up but you're in the health
world so I'm wondering like how is
strolling because it's not like it's a
big margin game this is not a big profit
game you know so they have especially
now that Jake wood there's a new owner
it's going to be interesting to see the
decisions they'll be making moving
forward but going back to come back to
well un retirement I got asked this
question from you man I got asked this
question for me so one question is the
one and I asked you young guys coming up
okay and then I'm gonna get to my next
question
who are some of the young guys that
you're looking at I mean you're you're
the veteran of veterans who's still in
the game
there's nobody that's a bigger veteran
than you that's a winner you know it's
kind of like a guy who's plank and he's
still winning right who do you look at
and say that guys can have a big future
he can compete that guy could win in one
day he definitely could win it one day
what are some names that you're looking
at Patrick Patrick can um he's got to
bring up a lot of body parts ladies
gotta bring his legs up big time but he
has a bright future he's got the small
waist and all that stuff but he's got to
put on some forties he got to get
thicker that comes in time that's most
of maturity I come to time so you can't
rush the product as long as you don't
rush the process and it takes and do
like I did put a little bit on each year
and keep all the negativity out keep his
mouth shut
he can go places yeah I actually told
him this myself you know a lot of these
young guys come to me for advice
wouldn't anybody keep your mouth shut
and negativity what does that mean just
being you know on Instagram or social
media and complaining about this and
that and and going back and forth with
people cussing people out and you know
Sergio did that for a while he's finally
calmed down with that but Sergio could
definitely you know he can definitely go
places I like Steve cool clothes Steve
Steve can keep his head on straight and
continue doing what he's doing and
totally stomach you know I told him I
helping with that
I don't see why he can't you know be one
of the main guys coming you know in the
future when I'm gone
winning I don't know about any guys
winning okay because you know that's up
to the judges I can't predict the future
but if they keep a head on straight they
got a good chance of maybe winning one
day right Kukla get cool close - yeah I
put them in there yeah because I'm you
know I'm getting ready to retire and you
know but you know you can't you can't
put Roly and you can't put William and
all these guys they they older now hmm
you know Sam we talking about the
younger guys what you say and you know
so those are eat well leave his Steve's
getting up there there but he's still
considered one of the younger guys
because he's just starting to get up top
with us right I mean they call you so
anybody there you say I like this guy's
physique you look out for this guy
long shot but look out for this one guy
any name well I would have to say Pat
repect was the hardest name coming in
but what but but what a lot of people
understand I told these people my listen
Patrick can be great but he's not ready
that's the same thing you just say they
feel I should tell Phil that himself
that's why he should want to beat me so
bad he's not ready right now and you saw
that because he's done only small shows
and you saw that once he stopped on
stage
I guess I'm Olympia you know that's it's
gonna be a different ball game I told
everybody that coming into the Arnold
you know what I'm saying
but not to say that he can't be good I
mean when I first came in I wasn't you
know I was ninth ninth eighth in Olympia
mm-hmm and then I finally started doing
something you know what I'm saying like
Phil Phil ran for three years before he
could be this first Olympia you scared
to compete against us yeah I say they
feel but once he came into his own you
know stopping him
same thing with with um Patrick if
Patrick
continue doing what he's doing putting
on size in the right places
I think he can definitely win and let
the in the future in the future okay so
outside of those three names you don't
have another name those are the three
names you are you if you thought some
things out of 10
I can tell ya neighboring as of right
now I can't think of anything obvious
I'm just curious because you know and
everyone in sports you kind of look at
the next guys coming up thought maybe in
your world you guys are talking about
that this guy's got the goodies he could
potentially do something look out for
this guy that guy's got to get the game
only way the only way that I even notice
a person is when they getting a lot of
getting a lot of press from social media
you know I didn't know her patch of
weather till I started seeing them all
on social media everybody should it
doesn't did that you know if something
came up
it was like when he want I think he
wanted cower when he wanted care that's
when he started getting a lot of praise
yeah yeah his name is everywhere about
who everybody's dropping his name that
he could potentially one day winners
yeah you saying it that's that's another
validation and by the way Phil thinks
the world of you and you know that
already does a little boy feel things
level Today Show retirement your time
out retirement and you're very committed
to it very very committed to it to
retirement super committed to the
decision of wanting to retiring but
here's a but for you okay here's a but
for you okay you got on a classic okay
you got these competitions that you've
done mr. Olympia you want are no classic
you want right there's this something
new thing coming out I don't know if
you've heard of it it's it's called
athletic on right we've never you never
maybe if you've never heard of it it's
it's it's in a lot of talks right now
obviously you obviously know exactly
what I'm talking about me and sarcastic
with you you know
that's a whole different ball game and
the reason why I'm since a whole
different ball game
I don't think competing in athletic on
is necessarily the same as the other
ones because the benefits package is
bigger you just saw Phil just announced
that he signed with Danny and he just
signed with them on some things he's
gonna be doing I didn't see that but
that's good for him yeah he just Danny
is now representing him and he's got
some good things that he's working on
that he'll be announcing to you soon but
if athletic con comes out and there's a
big opportunity you mean to tell me you
wouldn't consider it at all to possibly
compete with those guys and you'd say
Vince trolling Pisa last one as of right
now mr. Olympia is my last competition
so that means there's a little bit of a
chance it's almost like the movie what's
that one movie with the Jim Carrey
uh see when I first got when I first got
wind of this competition you know rumors
were flying oh it's gonna be $500,000
for the winner of course I'm gonna do
that but then when they wind them down
then it was like well it's gonna be a
hundred thousand per category I'm like
wait a minute we do bodybuilders we
don't wanna bring the crowd we don't
want you to be making the most money
that right there gave me I'm like wait a
minute you know if we do one draw the
crowd why do people take it from us I'll
give you a different perspective
I'll give you different from the
business standpoint because you want to
get into the business side right okay
remember back in the days this cell was
what when you said in one interview said
you know why'd you become a bodybuilder
oh because you know I went to this one
show and I saw the girls screaming
saying oh my gosh look at this I don't
wanna I want to get this kind of
attention from girls cuz you you come
from a family of athletes you know you
played everybody in your family I think
you were a football guy you played
baseball you didn't play basketball you
were track and you've been good at it
right is your homework yeah so you
you're you're a guy that came from that
world so and they used to pitch you guys
back in the days and say yeah let me
tell you you know imagine being on a
cover of a magazine that was a big deal
no one cares about being on a cover
magazine today versus 20 years ago and
used to me right before whether it was
flex and you made a few thousand dollars
on writing that doesn't work anymore
today today you got to do it on your own
social media inside right so let's set
that part aside back then it mattered if
you want cover magnin you know muscle
mag reflects or whatever my absolutely
today may be athletic cons pitch is
listen forget about the upfront money
don't think short-term think about the
connections and the movies and the
opportunities and the commercials and
the shows so if I'm a Danny or Iraq
that's how I'm pitching myself if I'm
sitting behind closed doors I'm sitting
there saying listen that so I'll let you
know if you're just coming for 100 grand
we're the wrong show for you but if you
come in here to be part of the family
like let me let me a guy asked me
question he says I'm an actor okay
good-looking guy and he says I'm doing
work man but I'm having a hard time and
this guy's done some work he did some
work with Denzel he did some works with
some guys but he is the the actor that
should be getting more jobs but he's not
because he's he studied the right art
and he went to the right acting school
and he's asking me this question Pat
what should I do to get some play in
Hollywood I said look man I just gotta
taste something if I wanted to get into
Hollywood right now and I wanted to act
I would do whatever I could to get in
the right team this is what do you mean
I said if you look at nowadays actors
are making movies based on teams Adam
Sandler and four other guys keep making
movies together and the same guys that
were one is in the next one and the next
one and the next one right Vince Vaughn
and what is it Owen Wilson who Vince
Vince Wan and Jon Favreau and one of his
other friends you know whether it's
swingers or you know Peter that's right
hey you look at some of these guys and
they're kind of getting in a mix I don't
know I mean you know if a personality
like yours gets picked up and then you
get other opportunities maybe something
you ought to consider you know because
it's not every day like if I had you and
I'm your agent
you're marketable man are you freaking
kidding me it's like a 50 year old
looking the way you do no one can say
that in the world you realize there's
only one of you in the world if if we
were to put anybody above 50 okay
anybody above 50 if we even put anybody
about 40 Phil would be in a competition
if we wanted to compete but if we put
anybody about 50 who's even close no no
where to again that's a marketable story
I I can understand where you're coming
from but if the contest was closer to
the Olympia then Haim wise time wise I
mean it's with october/november
sometimes the members in September I'm
already doing all these shows now right
take a break then to Olympia then it
would be extremely difficult for me to
take another break yeah and compete in
November you know what I'm saying if it
was closer it would be a no-brainer well
how'd you do it in 2015 when you did
nine out of 12 and you won nine
competition there's all back to back
that's what I'm saying so if you can't
do that you can't do it again
no no they were all back to back all and
what timeline okay like this Australia
one you're doing
right okay I got you see them that make
sense so if you got if you got if you
got a show if you got the Olympian
because all my all the shows that I
competed in they'd usually run
back-to-back yeah okay and not split
apart okay
and what I mean by spread apart is ones
not in February and other ones in June
and other ones in December these shows
that I'd I want it was two weeks apart
and you were an example like when you
won masters mr. Olympia and you want
Europe in how long would those three
contests okay that wasn't in the same
year okay then give me the one where you
won nine out of 12 in 15 okay so it's
okay so say I did nine shows at 2015
right right so we start with the Arnold
yeah I do - Arnold the Australian maybe
- Grand Prix's and they're all
back-to-back how sokka's back-to-back
what's that timeline it can be I can't I
don't know the exact date sex dance but
it can be yeah four to six weeks
hold on I'm trying I'm trying to set you
up that there is a possible case but
hold on what you got you got the Arnold
and you got to show three shows after
right that's back to back then that year
had the Olympia and you had three shows
back to back those shows were over in
September I got it
I thought you want me to die at another
three to three months that's a lot of
work a gap so the game you actually get
the dates exactly when it's athletic on
and when is when is a store Olympia mr.
Olympia is what second week of September
third second week second week okay
October 10 to 11 is athletic on so it's
four weeks it's four weeks so there you
have it you get four weeks timeline
focus is before we I thought it was like
November something well I mean if you
think about this because you can still
stay true to your commitment of saying
I'm retiring in 2020
anyways I'm not trying to throw a wrench
and I'm sure the mr. Olympia people
already pissed off enough with me that
this is just a D can this guy who's got
a channel on entrepreneurship
because I just should be honest with you
I just had eight weeks and trying
progress that week after the Olympia
they just stepped up their game put more
money in that show and they pitching
hard to get athletes so you know
progress that week after don't let be a
so which one is product progress also
mr. Olympia order no no Prague is just
another competition like that is known
like athletic on but it's it's the
product problem you see them John
problem well I mean as a competition not
know how prestigious that show is gonna
be it's gonna be crazy you don't get me
wrong but being that it's in October and
it's only a month later hey I consider
it now because I seem we don't have any
information no one is telling us nothing
we don't even know how much money's in
the damn show good money baby it's all
about the money bro telling you it I
know it is because I know this is a
courier you know one thing about you is
you know you're you're a professional
this is your business
is where is all about the money Phil is
a failed tail show with all the time he
told arm if you put more money than I do
he wouldn't do it less he put more money
in it yeah that's the Arnold yeah but I
think what fillers doing this remember
how you said also is when you said when
you were training back in your 20s 30s
it was kind of like you know I can eat
anything in absent and I learned that I
don't have to do free weights because I
want her to take care of my joints so
you saw your peers kind of hurting
themselves squatting 800-pound said look
I'm gonna make some adjustments it's
that like the Machine dough you found
with your legs and how it helped you
build up and then you found out with the
apps with the probiotics you don't want
to tell us about they eventually will
maybe fill is also sitting there saying
this is about contacts and relationships
who knows no no no so we're not talking
about that what you say it was it's not
all about the money it's absolutely
about it because Phil wouldn't even do
it unless they put my money in the show
he wouldn't do what he wouldn't do I
know it's straight up told him if you
put my money in the show and I'll do it
then let your pay 400 thought these pay
that that's Phil that's your boys
talking like you and I let a cop I'm
talking you and athletic I'm talking
even I play and I don't work for any of
these guys you gonna say
but look now that now no I I got some
more time-efficient I've gotten so some
more information on when the show is
gonna be now at least know when the show
is okay okay we don't know exactly how
much money listen and this port yeah
when it says when you come if I were to
come out with a show and I put $200,000
in the show yeah I might have a lot of
great guys coming to that show okay if I
just put a little bit of money to show
and put like $20,000 in the show though
it was big name they got a communist
there's not enough money what if you got
150 million followers on Instagram Jax
you gotta think long no you got to think
long no he got a 50-minute not me
then it got no do like you don't think
Joe play Joe Weider played a big role in
our buddy Arnold I mean you got it so
you got about you I know you tried your
best again I'm just telling ya I don't
just know I don't benefit from it I'm
not in any I get calls and you have to
you have to know that out of respect for
all these guys what little call well I
get calls about sitting as an advisor
and I'm not coming from a place of
saying pitching or not pitching all I'm
saying is you just place second on
Arnold Classic going up against
everybody that's younger than you and
you look sick you look sick this is
absolutely listen and you got something
there that's a ton of that I mean they
don't mean I should put my my body at
risk by keeping release not I'm not I'm
not suggesting response no but you got
it you got to put all that and consider
a totally get it that's fine I totally
get it but this kind of gave us a little
bit more context no it's only four weeks
apart and you have you did now you you
have at least convinced me enough to say
hey I'll think about there you go that's
that's all we do yes it's only feel
couldn't even do that cuz he all
secretive is [ __ ] so he are secretive
well to be fair with everybody this is a
pretty secretive world you don't want to
tell us what you're doing to get your AB
straight because you don't want to give
you guys an edge your competitors in it
I mean we can get one
we could even get you to tell us one
small little thing about
but I told you yes you didn't even get a
little bit just out of fairness okay so
we covered that we covered athletic on I
want to talk about your best friend
three of Sean ray okay I want to show
video about what he said when he was
here with me
now obviously you know at this point
we've had who Dorian on we've had Ronnie
on we've had curry on we've had flex on
Sean on and just Wayne d'emilia which
which is going out here pretty soon and
Wayne Wayne Wayne dropped some Wayne
wasn't holding back with nothing which
was pretty interesting and now it's
obviously you so I'm gonna play what he
said okay but before you played okay
let's just go let me go ahead and give
you some context he are ready to rebut
it what'd he say it already
yes okay I saw that but I won't hear
from you I won't hear with you now
because I was gonna smash him after I
saw that video but now since I came back
in you're gonna be able to say he ain't
made it that way
then I'm gonna let it slide and I'm just
gonna play it anyway sport for just
entertainment purposes you know you can
maybe enjoy watching it
current era against your era no none of
these guys in the top ten the one that
could be the top ten would probably be
Dexter Jackson but the other guys know
the these guys are right where they need
to be for their timing and they're lucky
that Dexter's not 10 years younger
it couldn't be the extra fee was 10
years younger Dexter Dexter and his
prime couldn't make the top six of the
Olympia I was there well first of all my
first three years there are not my prime
mm I turned pro in 99 2000 2001 that's
when I compete against Chuck that's not
my prime my prime one till I had two
thousand five six and seven
that's my prime when Shawn would beat me
I was damn near ensuite 205
yeah that's when Shawn would beat me
when I started smoking Shawn I'm loved
Shawn left because he I'm not even
getting to all that but when I started
beating some of that older you know it's
older guys say here's the thing
everybody's always coming out trying to
compare you can't compare errors it's a
totally different
you know this air is totally different
from 90s okay those guys were sucked in
and sucked down in and I was eating full
five meals a to look like that nowadays
you got to eat your ass off to be full
you come in like that you can get smoked
cuz he guys are for these days two
totally different errors you know I'm
saying not to say to these guys and this
error can't suck down like that course
they can't right but it's all about
being for these days if you any flat or
anything like that you're done you know
so it's it that's why I always saying
you can't you can't why are you even
trying to compare as you can't do that
but but Jonathan them will beat me when
Sean beat me my first few years you know
he was Sean ray you know that last
Olympia I got photos you can see the
photos I've posted on my Instagram
mm-hmm I smoked on my last you know his
last year but he's Sean ray you know
what I'm saying
and and I got no problem losing the
shine okay but being my prime I would
definitely smoke John for sure you and
your prime you with deafness most
wanting me close I was 230 he was 200 so
232 let me ask you this question I'm
head to toe straight from head to toe
shiny he was it wasn't even even even
half straight at glutes man come on man
he was narrow he had no streets on his
quads
no our definite sign that's technical
question for you
technics lesson for you you've been
around the block for a while top five
bodybuilders in your opinion of all time
rank them in top I'm sure you talked
about these after that's your world top
five you can't put yourself into it I
can't put myself in there well Ronnie's
one Ronnie's first Ronnie and in air
smoke anybody in any error okay so let's
get that out the way now huh
okay okay to is I mean I'm not listen it
is this is not in any particular order
this it's just my top five well your
first is first left Ronnie's first guys
a guy other guys you can you can you
know you can swim around okay but I
would have to
a fill field is top five all day that's
two three
flex ass three four
and it's hard you know for that fit
I won't have to go with Kevin Kevin
LeBron you put top five I put Kevin top
four Kevin all-time best physique best
physique I could put him in the top five
you got one more names left I'm curious
coming from a multi-generational guy
here
I would say had he applied himself in
the gym the same as he did outside the
gym or if he applied himself his work
ethic was if his work ethic was great if
his everything was on point and he did
were you supposed to do I was at Chris
come here well he's your mentor is your
friend so I know you when you you're st.
Chris Cormier
I'm not saying Chris I'm not saying that
because of that I'm saying it because
it's a fact you'd put the real deal as a
top five if he if he applied himself the
way if if if he applied himself the way
I do myself any and we've seen the full
potential out of his yeah I feel that
Chris is better than flex if Chris
stayed out the streets and stop fooling
around with everybody and did what he's
supposed to do yeah of course
Chris Chris was bad bro Chris come you
put in top five yeah now that's that you
so you show you a few names just for
full disclosure we've loved that you've
left out Arnold you've left that Sergio
you've left out Dorian you've left out
Hany you've left out Cutler some names
here and you're still sticking to your
five well well I only think you met all
of those guys like I mean talking
everybody
okay well that's that's a different
respect that let's let's do a whole
nother tough okay great so you
disclosure to be fair when everybody's
watching you're giving your era people
you've competed against yeah fair enough
now give me stuff all-time all-time
all-time okay
still Ronnie's no being at all time
Ronnie's still number one for you all
time all time yes when you talk about on
stage competing against him
yes what did he look like when you're on
stage like a mobster here was it was it
the word unbelievable like it's
literally when Ronnie dropped and closed
backstage everybody mouth dropped Jay
Cutler everybody what was it about his
physique he's freaking huge and shredded
bro
that is respected that's the most that's
easy he's by far the most dominant body
build in history by far who's the
closest guy you made that look like that
Ronnie he's close is doing incredible
hug bro okay so we got Ronnie at the top
Ronnie's the go Ronnie's put him at his
own league of his own Ronnie is the I
don't know about the goat but Ronnie is
the most dominant bodybuilder of all
times first place right next on of
course okay let's see fill top five top
five respect next let's see Sergio
Sergio in his time I felt could beat
Arnold he was amazing what number we
have how many we got four you got one
more once you got Ronnie Arnold Phil
Sergio
Ronnie says you'll feel Arnold Arnold
top five
okay I can't my mind is blank right now
I can't remember so you got flex Kevin
Cormier Haney the J who would you put as
a father Haney Li a nice five okay all
right
leonie's fine so Ronnie first and you
got autofill Sergio Lee Haney well
that's not a no particular order
Ronnie's just first well others for
seconds nothing more than fifth you can
switch them all around but Ronnie's one
what you saying what you think somebody
could be Ronnie no you know okay well
we're looking like did you hear what
Ronnie said about Arnold did you know
what Ronnie said about Arnold or no what
do you think he said he said I showed
him a picture of a Arnold he says look
at that chest
he says if Arnold was competing in my
era would access to the things that we
had I couldn't beat him Ronnie just been
modest few things just being modest by
himself
yeah so so see Arnaz six months honestly
six honest Hall is hell for one so it
would be very hard to fill his legs out
to look like Ronnie Ronnie legs was
insane just by putting them next to each
other running at his best when running
had that small waist look some pictures
man I'm gonna get you inside on these
pictures now because now don't get me
don't get it twisted Arnold was amazing
yeah ronnie was saying I showed him this
picture I said Ronnie what do you think
about this Ronnie said just look at his
chest that's how he was comparing
himself but you're saying 620 have to
fill the legs
he's mathematic just because somebody
got a big chest I mean eight I don't I
mean what does that supposed to mean
there's a lot of martyrs who had one of
the biggest chess in the world yeah you
know did he ever play stop all wrong you
now if he would say that about look at
his legs look at his you know hamstrings
and he ain't say nothing he just said
his chest
see when you look at Ronnie you're gonna
say that about everything
he was complete you know what I'm saying
not to say that are known wasn't
complete but his legs were a little down
versus his upper body
you know you there's a reason why
everybody likes you okay
is here it's a guy that's one more Arno
classics than anybody else and you're
still not being diplomatic you're still
giving your answer to say here's how I
feel about this
that's right no wonder the guys feel the
way they do about you so let's look at
some of your pictures here man why don't
we look at the the most important type
of pictures here okay when you see
yourself in some of these pics I'll show
them to you what do you think when you
see this guy whoa he saw how about this
Sarah when was this um I don't know when
I was he's not a guy that sits there no
it's not a quote like oh that was an oh
nine September you know I'm the type of
dude when I look at my own pictures it's
like doesn't do anything I don't do
nothing for me you got to see me next to
somebody I got to see you next to son
you got to see me next to people yeah so
why don't I show you next to somebody
somebody that's somebody that's your
you're gonna like this one how about
this guy next to somebody yeah
oh you like this guy that's crazy who
were you here by the way that was the
young Dexter Jackson
how was he like trying to get girls by
there non-stop somebody was is that
probably order guys look little dude
back then man name when I start getting
in the little body like this and I've
seen all those girls screaming hey I
wanted the girls to so that's all I
wanted they thought about back then is
trying to get a girlfriend is that is
that a big part of the life of a
bodybuilder is that what it is a lot of
play a lot of girls like no no no no
that that's the beginning of my career
this not now I'm but I'm talking about
25 30 35 is that still where the
reaction you're getting is non-stop of
course you get that of course you know
you get all these girls out there that's
like people you know that says you would
ask gross but behind closed doors they
want to see what the muscles feel like
yeah why don't we do this let me show
these this comparison I mean obviously
you know which is which how do you how
do you view these two when you look at
them
your eyes or friend in our eyes of
course that's what I want Olympia so
what do you see when you see these
numbers a difference not much of a
difference maybe you know maybe a little
down from here because I'm older and
it's hard to have the same fullness and
muscle muscle bellies I have to do a lot
of work versus back then you'd like to
eat four meals in look like that I had
to carve up I had to eat ten meals ten
[ __ ] meals to keep my fullness
because mama is crazy
I'm older but my metabolism is even more
crazy because you're eating that many
meals I had to I would have really been
flat back then I didn't have to do that
and I stayed for so it's about making
adjustments you got to know your body
you know most people were trying to do
one I'm gonna do the same thing I did
back then when I did this when I won
this show you can't work that way you
gotta know how to make the adjustments
you got to know when you're flat when
you need to add more food when you need
to stop cardio you got to know how to do
all of this yeah that's what I've
mastered over the years
that's why I've glasses of law what is
it like eating ten meals a day I mean
that's got to be crazy to eat any other
day to be honest with you for the very
first time I had to do that I ate every
two hours I started at about 6 o'clock
in the morning 7 o'clock in the morning
every two hours I ate yeah and I
actually was getting hungry from meal to
meal so he was getting hungry I was
getting 100 from ear to me about what is
a meal define a meal a meal is one and a
half cup of rice with you know six
ounces of meat or that's so you eat six
ounces of meat type well as weak well
when I was carving up yeah then it was
probably four ounces also I've seen four
ounces of meat with one and a half cup
of rice every meal for 10 meals 10 meals
yeah how many times you go into the
bathroom I was going pretty regularly
regularly like two three times a day or
you have to
no cheating so much right any side
effects of eating that much like you
have headaches are you heavier are you
sleeping you know is a tougher to sleep
or now no because my body was because of
the great digestive enzymes I was
telling you about your secret sauce it's
a secret sauce
yes that's what it put it this way
they're so good
when versus they're no these the ones
that I take versus the ones that you get
out of the store and when you got out of
store you gotta carry every meal you
take one a day at ease that's it the one
you got one there's a those are ones you
were telling me that he's gonna tell
everybody about them we're gonna sell it
for two on the rocks of five yeah I said
we're gonna sell it but I'm gonna tell
you
oh my gosh if there ever was a good plug
in one of these bodybuilding you had it
right now if you get sponsorship from
these guys and put it in your gonna get
thousands of people clicking on is that
okay all right sounds good so next
evolution of diet anything we can learn
from for all your years of competing
anything that are not even a
professional bodybuilder when you're
looking at somebody that wants to build
that muscle you hear all this stuff
about one gram of protein per weight you
what things were stuff that they talked
about 20 years ago that doesn't apply
today because of how much more smarter
and wiser the industry's gotten any
major misconceptions with diet um
everything is pretty much around and
saying you know you got different stuff
with men these days of course that you
didn't have back then but the main thing
is bigger system what you're eating
that's number one you know you have
people that you know get on a diet in
and they don't see any results but they
miss him skipping two meals a day then
you're not following a full program so
via consistent with eating all your food
when you're supposed to do it yeah on
time every day it's very important and I
live by that you talk about Arnold or
obviously you wanted more than anybody
else what's your most unique story you
got with Arnold my most really unique
story my most unique story I got my own
any Arnold or with honor himself himself
himself I don't have you know other than
him actually interviewing me on stage
you know it's nothing like I've ever
hung out with him I've never hung out
with him before no Arnold stories normal
story okay onstage backstage uh any
animosity any fights any you know in
between any of that stuff taking place
with you or no you don't have them now
you're pretty easygoing guy
you're the chill guy you know no
controversy with you
yeah no controversy with me unless you
cross me anybody ever crossed your no no
no I don't put myself in those
predicament you know no situations so
that's why I'm cool with everybody you
know when they're stitching I try and
you know be the clown like that and make
everybody laugh you know what I'm saying
but what did I mean that I'm up is that
just your person that's just me you know
and but one thing I am I'm a straight
shooter if you don't want to be told the
truth don't I'm very I have no filter
and I'm gonna tell you straight up
what's wrong and what's not wrong period
your November 29 it's a 29 no 5th 25th
who's your best friend and bodybuilder
my best friend and best body somebody
talked to every we're staying curly top
McCreary stand yeah in my nose day yeah
of course of course yeah yeah you know
he uh no I don't know him I know I know
like who he wasn't you can't say nothing
bad around but so okay today in
bodybuilding is there money to be made
in bodybuilding today the way it is yes
million but yes if you if but you got to
know how to go about doing it
it's not as easy as used to be one when
Phil and I was coming up you know or
flexing all of us were coming up but um
the social media has destroyed the game
when it comes to that easy money
so now you got to use your platform you
got to build your platform to be able to
make money and you know a lot of people
do
the training you know I got my own team
as well you know being you know you can
make you can make a good amount of money
off of different little things what's a
good amount of money
netting six figures yeah netting six
figures this is after you what you're
eating what you're putting in your body
travel you can still keep six figures
per year of course as a bodybuilder of
course what in the high six in high six
figures yeah well you have to be top
five or you can be a top tennis they can
be a top tennis they do it top tennis
still make high six figures if you know
what you're doing see I'm very very hard
I I'm like this if you can't afford to
pay me what I'm worth in I don't mean
when you start getting these guys out
here that start taking deals that ain't
worth taking yeah
then you have the the guy that's paying
this guy say well such-and-such did it
for this Dexter I'm like well I'm not
him
but then you get all these other guys
that's still taking it for what he's
getting it for and that's why the sport
is not growing when it comes to us
making money
mm-hmm you know what I'm saying I've
always said you know I wouldn't take
less than five hundred thousand dollars
from a farmer supplement deal because I
feel that I'm luring the standards of
the sport when it comes to us guys
making money you know money from current
you know contracts from someone make
deals or something so I would never take
a deal anything less than that you know
and I and and I would say but I'm
blessed and fortunate enough to say you
know what I don't need that deal I'm
gonna feed every showing weighing my
money and which I was able to do and I
didn't need a contract nothing you
didn't need a cop I didn't need a
country never got one auto show you
never got a conference I'm sayin no I
had contracts but when like safest is
one muscle attack one must have tech cut
us I said okay yeah head of the company
something a cop is coming with deals no
I'm worth more than that you can't pay
me what I was getting over here I don't
need it so I start winning all the shows
that's how I made all my money but I was
fortunate to be able to do that I was
blessed to be able to do that everybody
can't do this
what I'm saying on the go and take that
money you see them saying got it but me
I would never you know I would never
take something that I'm not worth it has
to be my worth because I feel that I'm
letting this you know I'm dropping the
standards of the sport so I've never
done that
post-retirement are you planning on
doing whatever you do with your
businesses within the industry like
supplements yes I got bingo fuel yeah I
definitely got my own stuff in Atlanta
get rid of the largest Dexter Dexter
series so I'm here ready to launch that
and and a few other things I'm not going
to medicare you are you gonna have that
probiotic part of your accent or no I'm
working on multiple all I'm saying is if
you are doing something with that
because if it's that effective let me
tell you that's it that's a good way to
position yourself I'm working on
multiple things that's good you know
what I'll go ahead and let the cat out
the bag I'm gonna tell you exactly what
these pills do for you you know not only
other digestive enzymes and their
probiotics but they shrink they're
larger small intestines so all these
people if you had these bubble guts
mainly because the intestines are you
wanting to get hundreds of text messages
after this video comes out cause that's
what you're trying to do no I'm not
gonna take any calls and no messages
there like that because I intended
nobody nothing until I'll retire anyway
you know I'm saying because based on
what we just talked about today go away
anytime soon okay speed run I'm gonna
give you a name tell me the first thing
that comes to your mind
all right guy Dorian Yates grainy grainy
Ronnie Coleman the greatest Kevin LeBron
no you don't know we kept on the bone
I don't know word to say okay god what
I'm saying is you had him in your top
five earlier
ya know you got respect he's he's one of
the greatest okay Brandon Currie Brandon
Currie um amazing guy waned Amelia he
cool with me David Peck II don't know
him well Jim Mannion
The Godfather Shawn Rhoden sound Roden
very good friend bow neck very good guy
as well Dan Sullivan
I've known there for many years and he's
like a brother to me
big Rami gentle giant Arnold man what
can I say he's like Michael Jordan of
the sport of bodybuilding charles glass
the greatest trainer nia ever chad
Nichols Chad um chad has always been
good to me so he's a good guy Phil he
feel amazing person Courtney oh that's
big bro
Jay Cutler keep it real flex wheeler
flex he's got the best I would say
probably the best symmetry and the sport
about of in history kai Graham Kai
he's weird but such amazing dude
so she'd complement right there took a
to call somebody weird what amazing dude
yeah I mean he is I mean he draws and
[ __ ] in here he seems like everything
yeah I love that guy I love Kai he's a
good guy Shawn right son son
controversial and it's comfortable yes
he is athletic on it's gonna be huge
it's gonna be huge and I don't know if
you know or not there's little rumor
rumor has it that if you haven't heard
this already there's this guy that the
bodybuilding world follows tremendously
and he's loved by many rumor has it he
may consider competing his name is
Dexter Jackson it's just the man the
myth the legend may consider this I had
a blast with you
really I don't mess with you and you
know again I'm not in the world every
time the guys come it's always
interesting for me to get to know the
personalities but everything I heard
from everybody you're exactly what
everybody said about you oh really yes
everything was respect when I tell
everything everything was respect there
was no angle with nothing all your peers
competitors everyone that I'm in contact
with there you know the names everyone
gave you a lot and it's very obvious
they have this kind of respect for it
because at the end of the day when you
compete at the level of you do for this
menu
there is nothing more exciting than to
have the people you competed against
have this kind of respect for you and
these are some people that you went
hardcore with and they still respect you
the way they do so from me to you I
respect you for coming out being a guest
I had a blast with you I'm looking
forward to seeing what crazy things
you're gonna be doing I know you got to
go to Australia I know you got to
prepare for a mr. Olympia and possibly
athletic on but future looks bright
brother thank you so much for coming up
man thank you really enjoyed it they
enjoyed it so if you enjoyed this
interview would Dexter Jackson and you
want to see more topics on bodybuilding
I got two videos I want you to watch one
of them is a video I did who replaced
Joe Weider it's a technical video that
if you want to find out what I think
click on this link to watch this and if
you haven't watched the Shawn ray
interview specifically since Shawn Ray
and Dexter went back and forth click you
to watch Shawn race interview and if you
haven't subscribed to the channel please
do so thanks for watching everybody
take care bye bye
you
[Music]